the jurogan experience there's something
special and we're going to kick this off
with a bang
uh-oh yeah something i don't know about
something you don't know about
uh-oh but we'll get into it okay yeah
special
yeah tell me you can do it now sure
awesome let's do it what's happening
well you
and your team you uh picked
fight for the forgotten uh my nonprofit
as
charity of choice with buffalo trace yes
and we're gonna do something really
special for
all your fans oh but first um
i wanted to do something i talked with
bo beckman his great grandfather's great
grandfather
i think his name's like th i don't know
eckert or something like that
he um he started basically the modern
day
bourbon in america so anyways i asked
him i was talking with bo
and said can we do something special for
joe and he was like yeah
what do you what are you thinking and so
i talked with my buddy ryan who's the
vice president of our board
and we thought about it and we're like
what if we could get a barrel
from buffalo trace and we could give it
to joe
and so we thought we'd do a sample
tasting for you
and you get to pick a single barrel
select
basically i guess i'm not a whiskey
connoisseur but basically you're about
to be able to do a wine
or not wine but whiskey tasting really
you're gonna be able to pick out your
own
buffalo trace barrel that doesn't taste
like any of the rest
what i didn't know about barrels of
whiskey is that
what is it they come from like 70 to 90
year old trees
and then each one of them starts off as
kind of like this moonshine looking it's
clear when they put it in the barrels
but then the the taste of whiskey comes
from like 67
of the taste comes from the barrel
itself really yeah
but the trees are all different trees
right
so those things i think they call them
staves or something it's like uh
28 to 35 of those things that make the
barrel but they come from all these
different
flats yeah the wood slats and so they
all taste different
every barrel whenever it's a single
select barrel so i guess like what they
do at buffalo traces they take a bunch
of those barrels and they put them all
in there together so it has one
consistent taste
but whenever you just take one barrel
it's always a unique flavor
okay so we got a few of them for you to
try goddamn whiskey nerds
i'm not a whiskey nerd but here we go
here's going to be sample one
let me put that maybe to the left or
right
try to test these yeah but here here's
the idea
like i'm going to get hammered again
need glasses
we got him right here oh he's got my
fingers
so do you like yours with water in it or
no no
wait am i girl well this this is the
idea
or this is how we wanted to say thank
you is you used to pick your own
thing yep here's the glass oh this is
hilarious
but this is why we're doing it it's
nerdy sure
oh this is pretty great don't worry it's
not a negative yeah
here here's why we're doing it is we
wanted to say thank you from fight for
the forgotten and buffalo trace because
we're about to do this big raffle for
fight for the forgotten
but you'll get 220 bottles yourself from
whatever
whiskey you choose 220 bottles of
whiskey yeah but what we're gonna do
chris are you trying to kill me
no we're trying to give you a gift that
you can give your guest okay
if you would like i would have the joe
rogan experience logo on it
i'll have a thank you from fight for the
forgotten so this is sample number one
that's sample number one going to the
left
with sample number one sample number one
i'll give a little right there
and then it's gonna be a real problem
this episode i might start crying
[Laughter]
this is sample number two okay i can
tell you about them actually
can you really a little bit specifically
i like how they come in these little
like
whiskey uh flask type deals yeah so they
took this straight from the barrel
and each one of these should have a very
distinct or different taste
and so basically you can choose it i
mean
you can figure out i don't know if you
want to take notes that's real nerdy but
they gave me one of these
those are great guys what is it nerds
like hints and tastes
you do bear one two three four no no no
no no no you're gonna remember
we'll do this right here by the time i
get to barrel three it's just guess
work i did a pot uh tasting thing once
it was uh pot tasting candy yeah it was
a um cannabis cup i was one of the
judges
it was ridiculous i was uh obliterated
by the time i got to like the third or
fourth
choice i had no idea where i was so i'm
like i couldn't feel my legs
all right so let's try number one sample
number one is seven years
and nine months old okay came from
warehouse l
for on the fourth floor tastes good
tastes good
very good so now you would have to
choose if you want those trays they make
a damn good whiskey yeah they do
all right they've been so good to us
that's number one now i'm trying number
two
i feel like such a dork i'm smelling it
and [ __ ] like
you know i do that at once like if i buy
a glass of wine a restaurant they pour
it for you they let you smell it
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm doing i
pretend you would know there's this
i i've asked that too because i used to
serve it i'd be like why are people
doing this this seems so
dumb no one's ever given one back on a
rare occasion you have to send one back
because like something
one time i did have to send the glass
back by the glass because i think they
had it open too long i was like
i'm sorry i never do this but i go this
tastes like vinegar it's terrible
yeah it can rarely happen but you can't
but i think that was at a place where
the bottle was just sitting around
for like a couple weeks or something
nobody had ordered it there we go number
two
number two this one is eight years
three months old it's very good too
which one do you like between the two do
you know
they're both really good i don't know
yeah they do make
good [ __ ] whiskey like you t you can
taste the difference
like some people like how do you tell
what's the difference so this is this is
how bo said it all you got to do is
like if you have four pancakes in front
of you keep it simple
which pancake do you like the best
[ __ ] pancakes
it was three yep three's got a nice
taste
that's that's a little unusual or is
there anything three is eight years two
months old
so three the oldest uh actually
two is the oldest so far eight years
three months two and three are my
favorites
two and three that's [ __ ] one it's
guessing if you gave me one and said it
was three i'd be like amazing i have
good taste
so you could see if one has more
character like
a bolder flavor one that you think your
friends would enjoy more that don't know
much about whiskey
they're all the same they're all the
same i'm lying
i'm lying to these people i can't tell
the difference they're all great
i think three was slightly different
three was slightly different
but they all taste like two again really
good whiskey
you like three and two all right jesus
christ here we go
we're gonna do two and three i narrowed
it down two and three but that's just
like
if you gave me a bottle of one and told
me it was three i'd be like perfect
i really wouldn't know okay i'm just
lying here we go
here's three
it's real good all right here's two
i mean maybe there's a slight difference
between two and three let's just go with
three
it's good no three three is a magic
number according to your day last hole
three is the magic number
and that one was born october 25th
2012. all right perfectly that's when it
was born yay
so basically what we're going to do is
we're going to be able to do that and
make you a bottle of 220 bottles and
we'll have the joe rogan experience logo
on it
and then you can give it to your your
guest as a thank you for being on the
show
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience